I think my favorite bum bum dance move
would be it's like a old song Bam there
goes the nip slip Camila Cabello
appeared on BBC's the one show on Monday
and while she was showing off a dance
move featured in the music video for her
song with Ed Sheeran bomb bomb
[Music]
offers a wardrobe malfunction on live TV
but she quickly covers it up and
continues on with the choreography like
the pro she is I hope you didn't see
nipple yeah well you know what I mean
there was a bit of a wardrobe
malfunction I don't know what I saw
there was a flash of something
after the clip made its rounds on social
media Camila took the tick tock to react
to the moment captioning the video quote
when my stylist asked me if I wanted nip
covers and I said no obviously
regretting her decision in hindsight the
25 year old added a song to her video
reaction with the lyrics quote I wish I
had a time machine
I wish I had a time machine I don't like
it it's all right girl things happen but
back to her new single Bom Bomb many
fans are considering it to be the
breakup Bop of 2022 and they are
speculating the lyrics are about the
Fifth Harmony alums breakup with Shawn
Mendes
[Music]
Camila has yet to confirm the
inspiration behind the song but there
are some convincing Clues
the beginning of the song starts off
with lyrics about the ocean and well we
know Sean admitted this in late 2020. my
biggest fear is deep water and when it
comes to surfing the lost in Japan
singer shared photos of himself
shredding waves just days after the
couple announced their split in November
still need more proof here's another
clue we were kids at the start I guess
we're grown-ups now
but not everything works out fans of the
two artists know their relationship goes
back to when they were teens I really
think when you know you know and she's
been one of my best friends since I was
like 15 years old the pair sparked
romance rumors for years before
officially dating in 2019. he's the best
and I think we're really supportive of
each other but after two years of dating
shamila called it quits in November and
now as Camila says in bomb bomb
[Music]
baby
[Music]